sie haben sich fürchterlich darüber
geärgert es geht um die erstattung von
parkplatzgebühren und wie viel geld geht
es denn da ja also wir wollten
ursprünglich nicht für zwei wochen nach
mexiko reisen und es geht um diese
zweieinhalb wochen wo wir den parkplatz
ruft haben am flughafen stuttgart
es sind in summe 206 euro und ab chor
ist halt der meinung uns mit 50 euro
kulanz abspeisen zu wollen
und sie fühlen sich da auch ungerecht
behandelt oder wie verstehe ich ihn
ärgern
ich fühle mich ganz ehrlich verarscht
weil unser reiseveranstalter byebye
tours hat unsere reise storniert und hat
anfang august auf nachfrage noch gesagt
ja ja die reise findet statt alles gut
alles super so ich weiß aus erfahrung
man muss halt parkplätze rechtzeitig
buchen also haben wir die nach dieser
bestätigung gebucht und meiner meinung
nach corona ist man halt eine
sondersituation wo eben auch ab chor
sein muss ja alles klar ihr könnt den
parkplatz aus gründen nicht benutzen
wir geben euch das geld zurück weil ich
rund 60 kilometer vor dem flughafen
entfernt ich stelle jetzt nennt mein
auto für zweieinhalb wochen dahin nur um
den parkplatz benutzen zu könnten so
reden die sich raus und fühlen sie sich
denn auch von der firma letztlich
irgendwie aufs glatteis geführt er aber
ganz gewaltig weil ich habe bei buch um
die agb gelesen es steht in keinster
weise etwas drin das stornierung nicht
gegeben ist und es wird sich ständig auf
die agb verwiesen
ich habe mich auf einer reklamation
webseite bei den beschwert ich haben
versucht mit den zu telefonieren ich
habe versucht mit ihm über email mit
denen kontakt zu treten
es wird einfach nur mit konservendosen
texten umsicht zu geschmissen
mit der aussage ja wenn sie wollten
könnten sie den parkplatz benutzen oder
halt eben ja geben sie uns für nächstes
jahr einen genauen termin wann sie denn
dann fliegen das weiß ich doch jetzt
noch nicht ob ich überhaupt fliegen
nächstes jahr ich bin stinksauer
ja das wird das merken wir und das kann
ich auch verstehen wir haben auch mit
der firma apcoa auch kontakt gehabt und
um eine stellungnahme gebeten
da gibt es bislang keine antwort frey
hermes regt sich da fürchterlich auf
erkämpfte zurecht na ja ich würde hier
auch mehr kulanz erwarten denn das ist
in der tat ein rechtsproblem was hier
auf gedeckt ist und zwar einmal kann der
parkplatz noch genutzt werden der
parkplatz ist da der parkplatz ist offen
und die fläche steht ja zur verfügung
nur es macht eben überhaupt keinen sinn
und das ist eben das problem leistung
möglich aber eben sinnlos und diese
sinnlosigkeit ist nicht gegenstand des
vertrages das heißt das ist natürlich
ein einen parkplatz in der nähe eines
flugplatzes aber voraussetzung für
diesen parkplatz ist eben nicht dass der
flug auch stattfindet und das ist eben
das problem dass wir keine verknüpfung
haben des tickets mit dem mit dem
parkplatz wenn wir eine verknüpfung
hätten also über eine pauschalreise
beispielsweise mit der parkfläche dann
wäre das kein problem geld zurück aber
hier haben wir ja offenbar
einzelbuchungen und da ist es etwas
anders
und da sind wir tatsächlich auf die
kulanz des anbieters angewiesen aber
wenn beispielsweise der
reiseveranstalter hier zu spät abgesagt
hat und dieser folge schaden der durch
diesen parkplatz entstanden ist darauf
zurückzuführen ist weil neben der
veranstalter zu spät reagiert hat dann
kann man die kosten auch an den
veranstalter weitergeben denn dann haben
wir einen schadenersatzanspruch ja das
klingt natürlich sehr einfach aber ich
habe auch den eindruck da wird es auch
kein geld geben frau hermes sie haben
das auch versucht werden vielleicht eine
alternative dass sie vielleicht einen
wenn sie vielleicht neu buchen oder
tatsächlich eine neue reise in aussicht
haben dass sie dann vielleicht diesen
parkplatz slot verlegen könnten das wäre
doch zumindest eine alternative wo sie
jetzt keine zusatzkosten hätten er die
fahrt chor die sagen hat also die wollen
ein ganz dicker hier also einen termin
haben das heißt ich müsste jetzt schon
für nächstes jahr buchen
ich habe mir ich habe gefragt ob das
nicht geht es diesen gutschein ist der
das gesamte jahr abrufbar ist
dies wurde verneint und stattdessen
wurde halt eben immer wieder darauf
gepocht nein es muss ein ganz dickes
muss ein termin sein
ich musste jetzt also wirklich schon
buchen und das ich weiß ja noch nicht
mal ob die nächstes jahr überhaupt
fliegen können und wenn ja ob dir von
stuttgart aus fliegen oder ob ihr von
frankfurt aus fliegen
das weiß ich jetzt mitte september doch
noch nicht